[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
discussing a bit of a controversial
topic
it's something that pertains to both the
students and professors of hogwarts
and it's definitely not something
positive i am of course talking about
corporal punishment if you don't know
already corporal punishment is an old
system of punishment
that was actually surprisingly common in
the school system
that is until it was banned in 1986 in
the uk at least
other countries went on to ban it at
different points in time
and i think that it may actually still
be allowed in some places
it's also worth mentioning that corporal
punishment also exists outside of the
school system
however the school system will be the
focal point of this video
corporal punishment involves inflicting
physical pain upon someone
and in a school setting it would be
administered when students failed to pay
attention
or gave professors flack though not
restricted to these methods
common methods of inflicting pain would
involve spanking or paddling
both of which are completely
unacceptable interestingly enough
however we do actually see instances of
corporal punishment
in the harry potter story most notably
this style of punishment is exercised by
severus snape
who would routinely smack students that
were taking the mickey
or failing to listen to his instructions
but i wonder
was snape actually allowed to do this
surely the magical school of hogwarts
doesn't condone this sort of behavior
right let's dive in a bit further the
truth is
the regulations involving corporal
punishment at hogwarts
seemed to be at the discretion of
whoever was headmaster for example
there was evidence in the text to
support a dumbledore was against it
professor umbridge seized mariessa
pulled around to face her and began
shaking her very hard
a split second later dumbledore was on
his feet his wand raised
kingsley started forwards and umbridge
leapt back from marietta
waving her hands in the air as though
they had been burned i could not allow
you to manhandle my students
dolores said dumbledore there is also
evidence in the gopro to fire to support
that mcgonagall was against it
as well teach moody is that a student
shrieked professor mcgonagall the book
spilling out of her arms
yep said moody no cried professor
mcgonagall
running down the stairs and pulling out
her wand a moment later with a loud
snapping noise
draco malfoy had reappeared lying in a
heap on the floor with his sleek blonde
hair
all over his now brilliantly pink face
he got to his feet
wincing moody we never use
transfiguration as a punishment
said professor mcgonagall weekly surely
professor dumbledore told you that
he might have mentioned it yeah said
moody scratching his chin
unconcernedly but i thought a good sharp
shock
umbrage on the other hand was all for it
as clearly shown in the
i will not tell lies segment from the
order of the phoenix
she also planned to introduce a few
educational decrees that would allow
hitting students
much to the delight of filch i've been
telling dumbledore for years and years
he's too soft with you all said phil
chuckling nastily
you filthy little beasts would never
have dropped stink pellets if you'd
known i
had it in my power to whip you raw would
you now nobody would have thought of
throwing fanged frisbees down the
corridors if i could have strung you up
by the ankles in my office
would they but when educational decree
number 29 comes in
potter i'll be allowed to do them things
this quote
also gives us an important bit of
information educational decree 29
so what does educational decree 29
actually
state apparently this decree would have
given argus filch
proper permission to physically punish
students for misbehaving
fortunately this decree never came to
pass however
there was something almost as bad a form
called the approval for whipping form
this form would effectively give filch
the same power that the decree would
and would allow him to hit the students
a dream come true for someone like filch
approval for whipping approval for
whipping i can do it at last
they've had it coming to them for years
he pulled out a piece of parchment
kissed it then shuffled rapidly back out
of the door clutching it to his chest
filch elbowed his way closer to umbridge
and was crying with happiness
i've got the form headmistress he said
hoarsely waving the piece of parchment
harry had just seen him take from her
desk i've got the form and i've got the
whips waiting
oh let me do it now filch had been
wanting to physically hurt students for
years
but under dumbledore's administration
never got the chance
this is reflected in the following
excerpt a highly polished collection of
chains and manacles hung on the wall
behind filter's desk
it was common knowledge that he was
always begging dumbledore to let him
suspend students by their ankles from
the ceiling
however when it came time for filch to
exercise his approval for whipping with
fred and george
they clearly weren't having any of it
very good argus
you two are about to learn what happens
to wrongdoers in my school
you know what i don't think we are
george i think we've outgrown
full-time education yeah i've been
feeling that way myself
i think they made the right move at the
right time however it wasn't
just umbridge that was a proponent of
punishing students physically
when hogwarts was taken over and snape
assumed the role of headmaster
the carros amicus and alecto effectively
had free reign over hogwarts students
given that they are well evil death
eaters i'm sure you can imagine that
they would have been just fine
with physically hurting students and
perhaps one of the worst
displays of corporal punishment i've
heard of apparently their preferred
method of administering pain
was the cruciatus curse if you can
believe it do you know about the caros
those two death eaters who teach here
they do more than teach said neville
they're in charge of all discipline they
like punishment in the carers
like umbridge nah they make her look
tame
the other teachers are all supposed to
refer us to the carers if we do anything
wrong
they don't though if they can avoid it
you can tell they all hate them as much
as we do
amicus the bloke he teaches what used to
be defense against the dark arts
except now it's just the dark arts we're
supposed to practice the cruciatus curse
on people who've earned attentions
i would say that administering the
cruciatus curse is probably the pinnacle
of corporal punishment
so it's fortunate that the carriers
weren't in power for long or
hogwarts would have had some seriously
disturbed graduates moving forward
however one thing that is worth
mentioning is that it appears that in
the olden days
that is the days before harry began
attending the school corporal punishment
was
far less frowned upon this is conveyed
in the following quote from vilch
in the philosopher's stone follow me
said filch lighting a lamp and leading
them outside
i bet you'll think twice about breaking
a school rule again won't you
he continued luring at them oh yes hard
work and pain and the best teachers if
you ask me
it's just a pity they let the old
punishments die out hang you by your
wrists from the ceiling for a few days
i've got the chain still in my office
keep them well oiled in case they're
ever needed
right off we go and don't think of
running off now it'll be worse for you
if you do
so it looks like corporal punishment
wasn't too far gone by the time harry
had started
as filch himself seems to have
participated in it
my guess is that it was actually
dumbledore that finally put a stop to it
when he took over
as headmaster generally it's argued that
dumbledore took over properly
sometime between 1956 and 1964.
so it looks like when snape hit ron he
was certainly in the wrong
however snape is snape so i'm sure that
it wouldn't have surprised the other
professors
very much what do you guys think did you
ever wonder if this sort of behavior was
actually
allowed let me know in the comment
section below
until next time it is the unknown we
fear when we look upon death and
darkness
nothing more
[Music]
you